l'objectif de ces entretiens pour le
gouvernement c'est de renouer le
dialogue avec les forces de l'ordre
il avait été quelque peu rompu avec le
début d'une fronde dans les rangs
policiers après les propos de
l'ex-ministre christophe castaner sur le
racisme dans la police et sur l'abandon
à d'une technique est d'interpellations
gérald darmanin qui survole omis
du quotidien des forces de l'ordre
reçoit donc un à un aujourd'hui les
secrétaires généraux des syndicats
policiers
les doléances sont nombreuses en dans
ces professions qui se disent dans la
souffrance depuis plusieurs années après
à des mots d'amour nous voulons des
actes d'amour ce sont les mots à dives
lefebvre d'unité sgp fo à la sortie des
rendez vous certains secrétaires
généraux nous hanter indiqué que le
ministre de l'intérieur souhaite et agir
qu'il souhaitait agir vite qu'ils
avaient eu la garantie d'une volonté de
faire de la part de gérald darmanin
milon après mieux la colère et le
malaise dans la profession ne sont pas
retombés je vous propose de les écouter
on a exposé nos revendications les plus
urgentes
j'insiste bien sur les plus urgentes ces
dealers aboutir au sans délai à savoir
notamment pour les collèges nuiteux avec
l'aspect indemnitaire pour arriver vers
ce qu'on appelle nous une indemnité du
travailleur de nuit du matériel des
postes fléchés pour ses nuitées pour
l'avancement
l'autre point essentiel qu'on abordait
aussi c'est redonner un sens au métier
de policier
pourquoi je fais ce métier de policier
et comment va se dérouler ma carrière
note pas ça ça passe par un avancement
ça passe la limitation dont une grande
réforme en matière de facilitation de
simplification des voix d'avancement
l'autre point aussi essentiel ton abordé
pas sur nice et partage totalement notre
analyse a tu sais la rentrée sociale
divatte est certainement très
certainement inévitablement bouillante
avec un impérieux besoin d'effectifs
dans les crs on a eu des garanties sur
une certaine volonté de faire avec un
budget plus conséquent notamment pour
2021 et avec une rallonge qu'on a eu en
2020 sur l'achat de plusieurs milliers
de véhicules
on lui a dit que malheureusement c'était
une bonne chose pour 2020 mais que
c'était qu'une goutte d'eau par rapport
à la situation et l'ampleur de la misère
entre guillemets de l'institution par
rapport aux sous moyens qu'ils avaient
nos collègues et notamment les
conditions matérielles de protection de
voix sur la voie publique les conditions
immobilière dans lesquelles ils
pouvaient exercer et les mesures
sociales qui était quasiment inexistante
de au sein de commissions et vous
l'aurez compris et les chantiers restent
nombreux
pour le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui recevra à nouveau les
syndicats policiers d'ici la fin août